SPEAKER 1: So we're going to
let you in on a little secret.
Something that this woman
doesn't know yet-- that's
Keeley.
And this man here-- his
heart is probably racing.
Adrenaline is rushing
through his veins
but not because they're about
to climb more than 13,000 feet
to the top of this mountain.
It's because of what's
going to happen when they
get to the top. [PIANO PLAYING]
STEVE: Hi, my name is Steve.
I'm a amateur photographer
living in Colorado.
This picture was taken
on top of the Grand Teton
outside Jackson Hole, Wyoming.
It was taken August of 2013.
So it's a picture of me
proposing to my-- at the time--
girlfriend.
SPEAKER 1: Steve had
an inkling that Keeley
was going to say yes.
But the journey to
pop the question
wasn't short on difficulty.
STEVE: So it was a
great but pretty tough
hike that required
some rock climbing
but it was probably the most
amazing hike I've ever done.
SPEAKER 1: After
camping mid hike,
the couple woke up around
4:00 in the morning--
rising even before the sun
to finish their journey.
But it was well worth it
given the view, the crisp air,
and the chance to be alone
with your future spouse.
Completely alone.
Which begs the question,
who took the picture?
STEVE: I set the camera on a
little, mini tripod on a rock
and said, hey come
take a picture.
When she came over
that's when I pulled out
the ring, got down on one knee.
I had a remote shutter
release in my pocket.
As I was proposing I
had the presence of mind
to press our remote
shutter so that picture
is the actual proposal.
The look on her face
is completely real.
SPEAKER 1: Though many couples
propose in sports stadiums
or with grand musical
numbers, Steve
understood that professing
his love to Keeley
would have to involve
their first love--
a love for adventure.
STEVE: Travel and pressure
is important to both of us.
Our first day was actually
going skiing up in Minnesota.
And then camping in the
winter when it was super cold.
So we've both been
pretty into it.
I've done three Iron
Mans in the past
and she just did her first
one a few months ago.
So we are both
pretty adventurous.
We hike, climb, ski
together, ice climb.
I had a very serious traumatic
brain injury last year
so that's why my speech
is a little laboured.
But I'm back to skiing.
Back to hiking.
So things are good.
Things are really good.
SPEAKER 1: Climbing one of
Wyoming's highest mountains
is an adventure in itself.
But for Steve and Keeley,
the real adventure
only began when they
started their journey back.
Sometimes love means
making a grand gesture.
And Kay Jewelers has the perfect
gift for your loved ones.
Kay Jewelers.
Every kiss begins with K.
To see just how diverse
the definition of
love can be, check out
this video on a worldwide
study of the meaning of love.
SPEAKER 2: love is project
combines social impact product
while connecting people around
the world through storytelling.
The focus-- the universal
meaning of the word love.
SPEAKER 1: And as
always, don't forget
to subscribe to our channel
Thanks for watching.
[THEME MUSIC]